دعاهم في اجتماع الى في مطعم الساعه
وحال وصول الرئيس حسب ما ذكر لي انتبه الى
عدم وجود شخص لم يذكر اسم الشخص طلب من
عندهم الخروج من الاتجاهين من الجانبين
بعدهم يعني بالقرب من المطعم من قصف
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام انا طاهر بركي
احييكم واقدم اليكم حلقه جديده من
برنامجكم الذاكره السياسيه نتابع في سلسله
هذه الحلقات
نتابع بالاستماع لروايه وذاكره الدكتور
خليل الدليمي رئيس هيئه الدفاع سابقا عن
الرئيس العراقي الراحل صدام حسين اهلا بك
معنا مجددا دكتور خليل ما حقيقه تخدير
الرئيس العراقي الراحل صدام حسين عداء
القاء القبض عليه
[موسيقى]
القي القبض على الرئيس صدام حسين يوم 12
وتم عرضه يوم 13
موضوع يعني اللي يشيع انه ضربه المنطقه
بالغازات المنومه موضوع ما اصل ولا لا صحه
نقل الي من محافظ صلاح الدين
الله يرحمها
لواءرك عبد الله جباره اكد لي انه من خلال
القوات الامريكيه
احد القاده تحدثنا والقائد هذا يشارك
بعمليه الاعتقال اللي يسموه الامريكان
الفجر احمر
يقول بعد ان تم القاء القبض على الرئيس
ويعني من المكان اللي كان فيه وهو ملجا
يعني محصن ضد القصف
الرئيس ما قبل يصعد يعني ويا الامريكان
بالطائره البلاكوك يقول فنادوا على المفرز
الطبيه
وحقنوه ابره مخدره يعني ماده مخدره
وصعد وياهم
طبعا معلومه لازم يعني اوضحها للمشاهد
الكريم انه الرئيس سبق وان تمت مداهمه هذا
المكان مرتين قبل هاي المداهمه والرئيس
كان في نفس نفس المكان ونجى يعني نجح من
الاعتقال لكن هذا هذه المره لانه كانت
وشايه
تم القاء القبر هي حقيقه خدروا خدروا
القوات الامريكيه
ولكنه لم ينقل خارج العراق
اختلفت بعض الروايات اللي يشكك ان وجوده
لا نقل الى احد القواعد القواعد العسكريه
الامريكيه خارج العراق
وبعد ما كنا نقابله لما كنت اقابله بيوم
اللي اخبر الجانب الامريكي يعني اطلب منهم
تحريريا عن طريق الايميل والعنوان اللي
اعطوني اياه
بعدها بسبعه ايام الله تيجي الموافقه فكان
الشك انه اذا موجود داخل العراق ماكو داعي
لهاي المده طويله اذا انت تاكدت منها
المعلومات لاحقا على ما يعني في مؤخرا
يعني في السنوات الاخيره لانه في معلومات
بكتابك عن اللي قالوا هو شخصيا لك تختلف
عن هذا عما تقول الان نعم بخصوص تخدير
وبخصوص نقله الى خارج العراق يبدو من خلال
حديثه معك كان متاكد من انه هو لم يخدر
ولم ينقل الى هو الدليل بيوم اللي يطلعه
يوم 13 عرضوه يعني كان زيغان
الزوغان العينين واضح جدا مخدر يعني كان
الوضع وضع غير طبيعي وحتى يعني وسائل
اعلام يعني اجنبيه اكدت انه كان مخدر واضح
جدا كان لم يذكر لك شيء عن هذا الموضوع عن
نقله الى الخارج نقله ما كان يعرف ما كان
يعرف لانه لاحقا فيما بعد يعني من كنت
اجلس وياه ونقلت لاحد الاطباء العراقيين
مقيم في السويد انه قال لي اوصف لي وضعه
قلت له كانت ترجف قال لي ايده اليمنى غير
ايده الاسرائيلي
يعني يتعلق بالقلب
اليمنى يعني معناته كان يعني يعطى سموم
وبطريقه بطيئه جدا وكان هذا المتوقع لانه
منزوفيتش تم تسميمه
الرئيس يعني كان يبعث رسائل لاسرته
تحرينا على هالموضوع انه كانت الرسائل
تسحب منه بدون علمه يعني كان يخليها
بجيبها ويعطى عصير قبل اليوم او بنفس
يعني قبل زيارته ساعات يعطى عصير ويتم اخذ
التقاط الرسائل دون علمه
اي رسائل تحديدا الرسائل الاسرته رسائل
اخرى يعني للناس الاخرين
فبهذه الطريقه دون علمه طيب قصه الحفره
التي وجد فيها التي صور انه وجد فيها
الحقيقيه او او لا هذه ليست حفره هذا ملجا
للقصف وان ما كنا يعني انا كنت بحيره
الاسماك في القاطع الجنوبي كان نفس يعني
بطريقه اخرى انه ملجا خندق للقصف
وكان محمي يعني من اي قصف قد يكون
الامريكان صور بطريقه يعني
هل قال لك انه يعني عن نوعيه التعذيب
الجسدي او المعنوي اللي تعرض له في
البدايه وكم استمر باللقاء الاول استمر 10
ايام باللقاء الاول كان يواغطون عليه حتى
يدليهم على المرحوم عز الدولي فوصل لحد
التعذيب
اللقاء الاول قدام الامريكان رفع بنطلونه
وعن ساقه
وشوفني الاماكن اللي يعني الاثار التعذيب
قالوا القسم الاخر يعني بساق الاخرى قال
اختفت يعني طول مده اختفت القسم الاخر انا
شاهدته بنفسي وكان الامريكان منزعجين ما
يعني بالضبط ما كان يريدونها لانه يخافون
لا اتعامل مع الاعلام وافضحهم بالاعلام
دكتور خليل من كان يزوره في المعتقل منه
المسؤولين العراقيين الجدد وباي اهداف
اخبرني احد الاشخاص يعني قريب من احد
الوزراء
بعد ان اخبرني الرئيس سالني قال لي في
مسؤولين بداوا يجوني شنو يعني شنو القصه
فمن سالتها قال لي كل اسبوع يجون اثنين
بعضهم يعني مؤدب
يعني ما يحكوا ما يتكلم وياه كثير يسلم بس
والبعض الاخر يجي بطريقه متشفين وحدد له
الاسماء اللي افتهمته فيه ما بعد من مقرب
من احد الوزراء
اجتمع بيهم
اياد علاوي على حسب ما نقل الي وطلب منا
الوزراء انه الذهاب الى
الرئيس صدام حسين
والتشفي فيه فاحد كل الوزراء وافقوا الا
احد الوزراء وهو من مشيخه من مشايخ الجنوب
ومن عشيره وقبيله معروفه ومحترمه رفض رفض
لا اسميه وزير الدفع الشعلان
[موسيقى]
ما ذكر بالضبط حازم الشعلان رفض رفض قاطع
وقال
رئيس الوزراء
اياد علاوي انه هذا مو من يعني من اصول
العرب ولا الرئيس خلص يعني راح ابرز
الاسماء اللي زارته او استفزته برهم صالح
قال لك انه شخصيا قال لا ما قال استفزي بس
قال ما كان يعني
وضعه مو طبيعي يعني ما كان لا محب ولا
كاره بس كان يسال يعني كثير سؤال وزاره
وزير السياحه ما اتذكر شو اسمه
وزير السياحه السابق اذا راى باختيار امين
كمان باختيار امين
قال كان مؤدب وسالني عندك مكان تزرع بيه
يعني حوض كان منطينه يزرع به وزارني
[موسيقى]
فلاح النقيب
ايضا تحدثنا معه في هذا البرنامج عن
زيارته هو تحدث عن زيارته له عدنان
الجماعيه مع السفير بوليبريمر والجيران
القوات الامريكيه اعتقد كان موفق الرباعي
واحمد شلبي احمد شلبي نعم
وفق الربوعيه اثناء الزياره
بماذا استفز يعني يقول كان يعني بعيد عني
وقف وكان يعني يتكلم بذاع الفاظ نابيه
يقول حتى القنا درس يقول مسكون الامريكان
وابعدوا عني
روايه
صدام حسين عن التحقيق معه ما الذي ازعجه
اكثر شيء في التحقيق معه طول ساعات طول
مده ساعات التحقيق يعني التحقيق يوميا
يجري لمده سبع ساعات
والامريكان طبعا الاذكياء بهذا المجال حتى
يوصلوه الى مرحله
الوهن والاستسلام بالضبط الاستسلام يعني
الضجر من التحقيق ويعطيهم ما عنده يعني
تصورهم انه الرئيس راح يضعف وهو كانت
اجاباته مثل ما كانت اجاباته لالك يعني
رايه باللي صار ومعلوماته
بالتحقيق جوله مع وجوله مع الاف بي اي
اللي قادها
ماذا قال لك صدام حسين عندما سالته عن
الانفتاح على الامريكيين في الثمانينات مع
نهايات الحرب العراقيه الايرانيه بدات
الامور يعني
تصبح بشكل سليم شيئا فشيئا مع الامريكيين
حتى
تدهورت لاحقا
طبعا احد اسباب التدهور يوم 7/4 الرئيس
ظهر يعني امام العالم
وقال يعني قول يعني المعروف مشهور اذا
اعتدت علينا اسرائيل او قصفت العراق او
الاردن اعتقد بقت احرق نص اسرائيل هذا
ازعج الامريكان واقام الدنيا وما اقعدها
بعد بيوم 13 بالشهر اخبرني قال انا كنت
بالموصل يعني فتره الربيع قال فاخبرني
السكرتير
قال لي وفد امريكي جاي والوفد يقوده
السناتور باب دول وطبعا بوب دول يعني كان
من السناتره من الصقور بباذنجون ماكين
وبزن
يعني الاخرين
قال ارسلت لهم طائره الخاصه وجابوهم هم
اربع اشخاص ومعهم سفيره
فالتقيت وياهم قال كان اول ما يعني حدثوني
كان بحده بعتب شديد على موضوع التصريح انه
ايش حرق نصف اسرائيل بالضبط انه هذا يعني
هيج العالم كله يعني هيج العالم كله ضد
العراق فايش كان مغزى
الكلام التصريح وهل انت جاد يعني بهذا
التصريح جاد بالفعل يعني ترجمه الواقع
وكان عندهم عده مطالب منها هيكله الجيش
العراقي انه دخلت
ب 15 فرقه وطلعت ب 60 فرقه ومنها لانه
يعني قويه كثيرا
بالحرب العراقيه بدا يخوف حتى الدول
العربيه قال من عندك خمس قاده عرب من
جيرانك نتابع بعد الفاصل دكتور خليل شكرا
بوجودك معنا مجددا مشاهدينا الكرام فاصل
قصير قبل ان نتابع ما لدينا في هذه الحلقه
مع الدكتور خليل الدليمي رئيس هيئه الدفاع
سابقا عن الرئيس العراقي راح لصدام حسين
وسطوني حتى يقبل يعني اثناء
المحاكمه ورفض ووسطوني حتى يقابلوا وايضا
بشده
ووصلوني حتى
يتكلموا معه يعني
بعد النطق بالحكم وايضا رفض وطلبوا من عند
الامريكان بيوم يعني قبل الاذان بساعات
انه يتحدث مع عائلته
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مجددا المشاهدين الكرام الى هذه
الحلقه من الذاكره السياسيه نتابع فيها مع
الدكتور خليل الدليمي رئيس هيئه الدفاع
سابقا عن الرئيس العراقي الاسبق صدام حسين
اهلا بكم معنا دكتور مره جديده في هذا
البرنامج اريد ان اتوقف قليلا عند بعض
ظروف توقيف الرئيس او يعني اعتقاله واسره
الزنزانه التي وضعوه فيها معاملته نوم
المرافق اللي كان فيها يعني ما ابرز مكان
يشكو منه بعد نهايه عن التعذيب والتحقيق
بالبدايه كان يشكو من معامله القوات
الامريكيه الى وشكم من بعض الامور وتم
يعني
يعني مقابلتي للجيران الامريكي
ويعني تم تعديلها باتجاه ايجابي لانه
كانوا يعني يخشون من انه الموضوع بالاعلام
فكانوا يستمعوا لطلباتك بالضبط وهو قالها
لك الرئيس انه عندما انقل لك ما اريد يعني
يحققونه لي مثل ماذا يعني كانوا هم يخشون
من يعني عندهم بامريكا حسب ما حدثوني انه
يحترمون مهله محاماه يحترمون المحامين
الامريكان يخشون من الاعلام يعني مثل شو
حسنوا بظروف توقيف يعني مثلا عند ما يعني
قابلته المقابله الاولى ولقيت شعر راسها
يعني شعره طويل وذقنا طويل عرفت السبب انه
يحاولون يجيبون يعني يعني ما كنت حلاقه
مستعمله فيثير حساسيه
جسده اي هاي اول وحده النقطه الثانيه
موضوع الطعام
وطريقه يعني اعطاء الطعام
بداوا يعطوه من طعام
القاده الامريكان المستوى الاول
الموضوع الاخر موضوع نومه كانوا يعني اما
موسيقى صاخبه يعني بطريقه قد تكون مقصوده
او قد تكون هي هاي اخلاقيات الجيش
الامريكي او جزء من افراد ايضا يعني
انهوها من هذا القبيل
طيب بخصوص
اتصالاته في الخارج هل كان يقبل الاتصالات
من العائله لا لم اقبل رفض يعني لم يتحدث
الى اي فرد عائله لم يتحدث خارج المعتقل
على الاطلاق وكل ما كان وهو في داخل
المعطاه في داخل لم يتحدث الى اي احد من
عائلته وسطوني حتى يقبل يعني اثناء
المحاكمه ورفض ووسطوني حتى يقابلوه وايضا
رفض بشده
ووسطوني حتى
يعني
بعد النطق بالحكم وايضا رفض وطلبوا من عند
الامريكان بيوم يعني قبل الاعدام بساعات
انه يتحدث مع عائلته واذا رفض لماذا رفض
يقول انا ابقى يعني بهذه الرباط الجيش
والكياسه وما ياثر على
يتاثروا
يعني مجال القوات الامريكيه انه بكره يعني
يقولون ضعف او عائله ضعفت
صحيح كان في عدد منهم يتعاطفون معه
يتاثروا فيه ويعني في علاقه تود بيناتهم
يعني كانوا الجنود واحد الضباط برتبه
ملازم اول تعلقوا بيه كثير حتى امر المرات
انا جالس معه وكان ملازم اول يعني
واصل الامر نقله
الى مكان اخر يعني يغيروه
فدخل عليه هذا الضابط ومع المترجمه وطلب
من عندي ان اكتب القاعده القوات الامريكيه
قلت له هذا سابقه الرئيس كان يعني على
امراه وما اسمع منه قلت لها هذه سابقه
يعني تحتسب التاريخي يعني
اطلب احد ضباط الاحتلال يبقى قال لي لا
الرئيس قال لي لا ابني اكتب وكان يعني
مبتسم اكتب اطلب انه يبقى هو المسؤول في
في
المعتقل بالضبط
كان متعلق به والرئيس ايضا كرد الجميل قال
لي لا اطلب اكتب وعلم مسؤوليتي فطلبت بقوه
ست شهور اخرى
ابقوه نعم هو نفسه اللي اجهز بالبكاء اجهز
بالبكاء بعد ما خلص خلصت مهمته بده يرجع
مسلم بالبكاء
بالضبط والمره اغتيل الزميل خميس عبيدي
الله يرحمه
ايضا في هيئه الدفاع الدفاع واضرب الرئيس
لمده 20 يوم يتصل الجانب الامريكي قالوا
لي يعني حالته بدات سوء فلازم تجي حتى
تقنعه فهذا الضابط كان يلح عليه قبل لا
ادخل انه ما تطلع من يمه الا تقنعه
وبالفعلته ايضا ضمني وضم الرئيس كيف تلقى
صدام حسين الرئيس العراقي الاسبق نبا مقتل
نجليه وحفيده
حكى لي هاي القصه قال كنت اني عند احد
المواطنين العراقيين من الاصدقاء
يعني كان كان عامل الغداء حتى نتغدى
فكان وضعها يعني يعني مرتبط
فسال الرئيس يعني ليش ارتباك قال له والله
اني يعني سيدي اني مخفي عليك خبر قال له
خير قال عدي استشهد يقول قلت العافيه
وقصي استشهد يقول قلت له عافيتين قال لو
مصطفى ايضا استشهد
فحكى له الواقعه انه عمليه مقاومه مداهمه
والاولاد الله يرحمهم يعني ابناء اقاوموا
حفيده قاموا القوات الامريكيه ومصطفى نزل
قصي
على وسائل الاعلام كانت وشايه ايضا نعم
كانت وشايه من الشخص اللي اللي استضافهم
الداره وطبعا بماذا الاموال اولا هو صفه
الغدر يعني موجوده يعني هي صفه للاسف يعني
في بعض الاشخاص هي غريزية هو مش قريبهم
كان يدعي انه انه يعني من عشيرتهم وكان
يعني محاط بعنايتهم ومحاط برعايه خاصه
علاقه قديمه
واثروا عليه بالمال واثره علي يعني بكل
النعم اللي موجوده
طبعا
بالخمسه وعشرين مليون اللي اعطوه اياه
القوات الامريكيه 25 مليون دولار
يعني مكافئه
كيف كلفك صدام حسين باجراء اتصالات هل هو
تكليف منه باجراء اتصالات مع المسؤولين
والقاده العرب او كانت مبادره منك
او منهم
باحد اللقاءات اخبرني انه يعني كاتب رساله
ويطلب مني ايصالها الزعيم عربي كان على
علاقه وطيده مع الرئيس يعني اثناء الحكم
وهذا الزعيم العربي يحمل من صفات
الاوروبيه
والشهامه العربيه ما يعني يعجز عن الوصف
المشكله هناك كيف اطلع الرساله يعني كيف
اخذها
عمليه اخراج الرساله
بطريقه معقده يعني الطريقه لازم تجانب
الامريكي يعني حذر جدا عندما امد ايدي
بجيبي وحذر جدا اذا اسحب اي ورقه استلمها
من رئيس مباشره
فبططريقه ما ما اريد اذكرها حصلت على
الرساله
يعني بالطريق تحمسنا نعرف كيف يعني على
الاقل
كان كنا نلتقي اني الرئيس بقياده قوات
الماريز قياده قوات الماريز هذا مقر لقاده
الجيش الامريكي ومقر ايضا للسجن كبار قالت
النظام الوطني
عمليا عدد القاعه اللي احنا فيها البقيه
الاماكن ما مراقبه فيروح الرئيس يعني يعني
يطلب
الذهاب الى الحمام اثناء السير يعني
بالممر يقدر يمد ايده على يعني جيبته
ويلتقط الرساله ويغطيها بمحارم فمن يغطيهم
محارم يبقى يستعملها يمسح بها وجهها
ويخليها على الطاوله اللي احنا قريبين
اقوم انا يعني تقطيع يعني عدد من
[موسيقى]
هاي المحارم ووضعها بيني وبين الرئيس حتى
اغطي على الاولى فمن اسحبها خليها فوق
الاجنده لانه ما اقدر لا اخليها بالاجنده
او بين اوراقي ولا اخليها لان يراقبونا
الامريكان من مكانيا متقابلين من نوافذ
زجاجيه ضباط يراقبوننا ناهيك عن الرقابه
الالكترونيه اللي اكيد احنا محتسبينها
بهاي الطريقه احمل الرسائل القاده العرب
شو كان في حواها فحواها بالبدايه يعني
سلام وعتب على هذا القائد انه يفترض يعني
من حق الكبير على اهله هم اللي يسالون
عليه لكن انا اتجاوز الظروف المحيطه به كل
المحيطه بالعالم العربي واني اسلم عليك
يعني بادرت من عندي انه تستخدمون علاقتكم
مع الجانب الامريكي لحقت دماء الشعب
العراقي ولحقن دماء اصدقائكم الامريكان
وراح تكون المبادره مقبوله منك كون يعني
ثقلك العربي وثق لك بالعلاقات الامريكيه
احنا ننتصر بالاخير وانا ما اطلب منك
النجده للنجده رقب رقبه صدام حسين وانما
اطلب من عندك حقن الدماء
[موسيقى]
الجنود الامريكان
والمقاتلين العراقيين ما بتتعلق بمصيره هو
شخصيا لا لا
لم تؤتي ثمارها لعوامل يعني دوليه بموضوع
عرض المغادره الى احد البلدان العربيه
ايضا حتى اخر الايام ظلت هذه العروض ساريه
على الرئيس الاسبق وكان يرفضها في احد
الجلسات مع الرئيس صدام حسين طبعا القائد
المعتقل يتغير فاخر يعني قائد المعتقل
امراه ضابطه امريكيه اسمها سات
فدخلت هاي القائد الامريكيه ومعها
المترجمه
وطلبت من عندي ان لا اذهب بعد اللقاء مع
مدير مكتب الارتباط الامريكي
مايكل ماكوي وانا اذهب معها فالرئيس كان
منتبه ورا ما طلعه وقلت له ماشي يعني
وافقت ما يفرق يعني سواء القاعده او رحت
ويا الضابط الاخر
بعد اللقاء
الرئيس اهتم بهالموضوع قال لي هذول عندهم
مبادره وعندها رساله تبلغك بيها اريدك
تجيني ترجع لي باسرع وقت كان بذلك الوقت
اللقاء بالشهر مره واحده
قال لي احتمال اذا هم يعني محتاجين هاي
المبادره توصلها ليا راح ينطقموا يعني
ينطق فرصه اخرى للمقابله خلال بالفعل ورا
ما اتوادعنا رحت لقيتها هي تقود المدرعه
اللي انقل فيها قلت لي
اني احمل مبادره ان تطلب يعني بحكم محبه
الرئيس الك واعتزازه فيك واهتمامك وثقتي
فيك احنا قواتنا في وضع حرج جدا بالفلوجه
تقاتل يعني تنظيمات مسلحه وما ولا يمكن ان
نسمح لامريكا ان تهان فاحنا اما ان نريد
الفلوجه عن بكره ابيها بسلاح نوعي او
تعاني امريكا ولا يمكن ان تهاني ان نسمح
بها انت امريكا العرض هو ان يخرج الرئيس
يكتب لك رساله للشعب
يكتب ما يشاء بها بس
لبه الرساله لب الرساله انه يكتب يطلب من
المسلحين وقف القتال وقف القتال والتفاوض
مع القوات الامريكيه مقابل هذا الى يعني
حددوا عده منها يطلق سراحه ومنها يطلق
صراحه فورا خارج العراق خارج الى خارج
العراق
حددوا له ثلاث دول عربيه يختار اي دوله من
هاي الدول العربيه
واكدوا لي انه يعني جيبه متصل بالخزينه
العراقيه يعني ما يشيل هم الامور الماليه
او الامور المعيشيه ما يكتب مذكرات
يعتزل السياسه
ما يلتقي باحد يعني مجرد يعني حياه وحددوا
ثلاثه عواصم عربيه حددوها
[موسيقى]
يعني ماذا قال لك عندما عرضت عليه ذلك رفض
نتابع في بدايه الحلقه المقبله الدكتور
خليل شكرا لوجودك معنا مجددا مشاهدينا
الكرام نتابع واياكم في سلسله هذه الحلقات
مع الدكتور خليل الدليمي رئيس هيئه الدفاع
سابقا عن الرئيس العراقي راح صدام حسين في
بدايه الحلقه المقبله الى اللقاء
بعد ما طلب الرئيس ووضع وضع خطه ركن يعني
القوه فوج لتحرير او قوه اي قوه فوج
لتحريره مشغله المطار مشغلات المنطقه
الخضراء القضاء عليه وخطه كامله متكامله
وتمنقل المعدات الى القريب يعني على
الموقع اللي هو فيه طلب مني ان يعني انقل
هاي الخطه
النائب المرحوم عزت ابراهيم
ليضع يعني لمسات عليها
[موسيقى]